Music, conversation, bird song, a truck backing up, the hum of a refrigerator, the leaf blower across the street. We live in a world of constant, complex sound, yet most of us don't spend very much time thinking about the role that sound plays in our lives. Polls find that most people, when asked to rank their senses, values cite the highest with hearing a distant second. But sound is integral to our lives, even to our mental health. and no two people's sonic world is exactly the same. Our life experiences shape the way that our brain processes sound, and sound is deeply intertwined with everything from our ability to read to our cognitive health as we age.
音乐、谈话、鸟鸣、倒车的卡车、冰箱的嗡嗡声、街对面的吹叶机。我们生活在一个充满持续、复杂声音的世界里，然而我们大多数人并没有花太多时间去思考声音在我们生活中扮演的角色。民意调查发现，当被要求对感官进行排名时，大多数人认为视觉价值最高，听觉则远远排在第二位。但声音对我们的生活甚至心理健康都至关重要。而且没有两个人的声音世界是完全相同的。我们的生活经历塑造了大脑处理声音的方式，并且声音与我们的阅读能力以及老年时的认知健康等方方面面都紧密相连。
So why is sound so undervalued, especially by those of us who can hear? How does our brain turn sound waves into brain waves? Do the brains of musicians differ from those of non-musicians? Why is sound crucial? to reading. Do other animals experience sound in the same way that humans do? How does unwanted noise affect our ears and our brain? Why does our hearing change as we age? And what can all of us do to create a better, healthier sonic world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
那么，为什么声音如此被低估，尤其是对我们这些听力正常的人来说？我们的大脑是如何将声波转化为脑电波的？音乐家的大脑与非音乐家的大脑有什么不同？为什么声音对阅读至关重要？其他动物体验声音的方式与人类相同吗？不需要的噪音如何影响我们的耳朵和大脑？为什么我们的听力会随着年龄的增长而改变？我们所有人能做些什么来创造一个更好、更健康的声学世界？欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Nina Craven Director of the Auditory Neuroscience Lab, also called Brainvolts, at Northwestern University. She's a scientist, inventor, and amateur musician who studies many aspects of auditory learning. The list of her research topics includes music, concussion, bilingualism, reading, aging, and autism. She has invented new ways to measure sound processing in humans and has conducted studies in traditional research labs, as well as in schools, community centers, and clinics. She is the author of hundreds of peer-reviewed research articles and speaks frequently to the media about sound and the brain.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是西北大学听觉神经科学实验室（又称Brainvolts）主任妮娜·克雷文（Nina Kraus）博士。她是一位科学家、发明家和业余音乐家，研究听力学习的许多方面。她的研究课题包括音乐、脑震荡、双语、阅读、老化和自闭症。她发明了衡量人类声音处理的新方法，并在传统研究实验室、学校、社区中心和诊所开展了研究。她是数百篇同行评审研究文章的作者，并经常向媒体谈论声音与大脑。
Her recent book is called Of Sound Mind, How Our Brain Constructs a Meaningful Sonic World. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Krause. I'm so glad to be here, thanks, Kim. So a moment ago, I mentioned that people tend to rate sight as their most valued sense far ahead of hearing Why do you think that hearing is so much less valued? Well, for one, it's invisible.
她最近出版了一本名为《有声思维：我们的大脑如何构建有意义的声音世界》（Of Sound Mind: How Our Brain Constructs a Meaningful Sonic World）的书。谢谢你加入我们，克雷文博士。我很很高兴来到这里，谢谢你，金。那么刚才我提到，人们倾向于将视力视为他们最看重的感官，远在听力之上。你认为为什么听力受到的重视要少得多？嗯，首先，它是看不见的。
And what we can see is right in front of us. What we can hear actually is all around us, 360 degrees. But we live in a visually biased world. And I think also as time is going on, we're forgetting how to listen and how important hearing is. sound very much connects us. It connects us with others. It connects us with the world in a way that is really different from the way we are connected with our other senses. Sound is evolutionarily ancient, sound processing in the brain, really derived from primitive organisms, from cells that would move with vibration.
而且我们能看到的东西就在我们眼前。我们能听到的是实际上在我们周围，全方位360度。但我们生活在一个有视觉偏见的世界里。而且我认为随着时间的推移，我们正在忘记如何倾听以及听力有多么重要。声音非常将我们联系在一起。它将我们与他人联系起来。它以一种与我们通过其他感官相连的方式完全不同的方式将我们与世界联系起来。声音在进化上是古老的，大脑中的声音处理实际上源自原始生物，源自随振动移动的细胞。
and eventually in vertebrates we have a complex auditory pathway, but the fundamentals of hearing and the vibrations that we are able to discern and that any organism can discern is evolutionarily ancient and biologically important. Now, you spend the first third of your book explaining the basics of how sound works. the ear and the brain convert waves, sound waves, into brain activity. What makes sound unique in terms of how it's processed in the brain? Well, first of all, even though light, the speed of light, is faster than the speed of sound, the way we process sound in the brain is faster. And if you can imagine, so right now as we're having this conversation, sound waves are occurring. And within every sound
最终在脊椎动物中我们有了复杂的听觉通路，但听力的基础以及我们能够辨识的振动以及任何生物都能辨识的振动在进化上是古老且在生物学上是重要的。现在，你花了书的前三分之一来解释声音工作的基础知识。耳朵和大脑将波、声波转化为大脑活动。就声音在大脑中的处理方式而言，是什么让声音变得独一无二？嗯，首先，尽管光速比声速快，但我们大脑处理声音的速度却更快。如果你能想象一下，正如我们现在正在进行的这次对话，声波正在产生。并且在每一个声音
wave, there is a tremendous amount of information that is happening in time. It's here and then it's gone. It only is present for a second or for a millisecond, frankly. And whereas what we see is something that is much more stable in terms of timing so that the timing requirements are going to be different. The brain needs to make sense of sound. Similar to, to how we make sense of a visual object, there are many ingredients that we right away are able to discern, you know, what is the shape, the size, the color, how heavy is it? And with sound, remember, sound, first of all, is invisible. And all of the ingredients are also invisible, but they are there. So if we give it a thought, we realize that sound consists of pitch, how high or low,
波中，都有大量的信息在时间上发生。它在这里，然后就消失了。坦白说，它只存在一秒或毫秒。然而，我们所看到的在时间稳定性方面要稳定得多，因此时间要求会有所不同。大脑需要理解声音。类似于我们理解视觉对象的方式，有许多要素我们可以立即辨别，你知道，形状、大小、颜色是什么，它有多重？对于声音，请记住，首先声音是看不见的。所有的要素也都是看不见的，但它们确实存在。因此，如果我们仔细想想，我们会意识到声音由音调组成，即有多高或多低，
the sound is. It consists of timbre. Tambor is determined by the harmonics in sound. Tambor is what allows us to tell the difference between two different instruments that are playing the same note. The harmonics enable us to distinguish one consonant from another, a gha from a ba. There is so much timing. I mean, in every single waveform. And Kim, you know, you are actually looking at these wave and you can see how they stop and start and how they have so many timing elements that the brain needs to make sense of. So the brain is processing, pitch, timing, timbre, phase, other ingredients with microsecond precision. And the signal, the sonic signal, the sound wave requires that that be done.
声音就是这样。它由音色组成。音色由声音中的泛音决定。音色使我们能够区分演奏同一个音符的两种不同乐器。泛音使我们能够区分一个辅音和另一个辅音，比如“ga”和“ba”。有太多的时间安排。我的意思是，在每一个波形中。金，你知道，你实际上正在看着这些波浪，你可以看到它们是如何停止和开始的，以及它们具有大脑需要理解的如此多的时间元素。因此，大脑正在以微秒级的精度处理音调、时间、音色、相位和其他要素。这个信号，声音信号，声波要求做到这一点。
Let's talk for a minute about the connection between sound and language, especially reading. People tend to think of reading as a visual activity, but your research has shown that sound is critical to our ability to read. Why is that? Well, it's not just my research. There really has been decades of research showing that sound is critical to the ability to read. So why is that?
我们花一分钟来讨论声音与语言之间的联系，尤其是阅读。人们倾向于认为阅读是一种视觉活动，但你的研究表明，声音对于我们的阅读能力至关重要。这是为什么呢？嗯，这不仅仅是我的研究。确实有数十年的研究表明声音对阅读能力至关重要。那么这是为什么呢？
We learn to speak before we learn to read. And again, if we draw an evolution, think about the fact that we have been. speaking and using sound for hundreds of thousands of years for communication. We've only been reading for the past 3,000 years. And in fact, Socrates was concerned that we would lose our ability to remember because sound and memory are very, very, very closely tied. But first of all, we have to make sound to meaning connections when we learn to talk. So that's the first thing that happens. And then if we have made strong sound to meaning connections, then it will be easier for a child or anyone to connect the sounds with a symbol on a page, a letter. And we can measure
我们先学会说话，然后才学会阅读。同样，如果我们回顾进化，想想这样一个事实：我们一直在进行。为了交流，几十万年来我们一直在说话和使用声音。我们学习阅读只有过去3,000年的历史。事实上，苏格拉底曾担心我们会失去记忆能力，因为声音和记忆联系得非常非常紧密。但首先，当我们学习说话时，我们必须建立声音与意义的联系。所以这是首先发生的事情。然后，如果我们建立了牢固的声音与意义的联系，那么孩子或任何人将声音与页面上的符号（字母）联系起来就会更容易。我们可以测量
sound processing in the brain. So as I'm talking to you now, the neurons in your brain that respond to sound are producing electricity and with some scalp electric. we can measure your brain's response to sound, and we can figure out how good a job your brain is doing at processing all those different sound ingredients that I spoke of, pitch, timing, timbre, phase, and we can see where are the strengths, where are the bottlenecks? And we can see that in children who have difficulty reading
大脑中的声音处理。因此，正如我现在跟你说话一样，你大脑中对声音做出反应的神经元正在产生电流，并通过一些头皮电。我们可以测量你的大脑对声音的反应，我们可以弄清楚你的大脑在处理我刚才提到的所有不同声音要素（音调、时间、音色、相位）方面做得有多好，我们可以看到优势在哪里，瓶颈在哪里？我们可以看到，在有阅读困难的儿童中
and who have delayed language skills, we typically see that aspects of timing and of the processing of the harmonics, which of course really do enable us to distinguish one consonant from another. I use the metaphor of the brain as mixing board. So imagine, you know, this complex sound that has all the different ingredients is coming into your head, and then your brain is a mixing board where the faders go up and down on these different ingredients, pitch timing, in timbre. And if you have difficulty reading, the slider, the fader on the harmonics fader,
并且语言技能发育迟缓，我们通常会看到时间以及泛音处理的各个方面，当然，这些确实使我们能够区分一个辅音和另一个辅音。我用大脑作为调音台的比喻。所以想象一下，你知道，具有所有不同要素的这种复杂声音进入你的头部，然后你的大脑就像一个调音台，推子在这些不同的要素（音调、时间、音色）上上下移动。如果你有阅读困难，泛音推子上的滑块，
is going to be low. And certain aspects of timing is going to be low. And so we can see, oh, there actually is a bottleneck. All you can see is, oh, here's a child who has difficulty learning to read. You don't know what's going, what's up with them. If you measure their sound processing, you can see, well, actually there's nothing wrong with their sound processing. Everything's perfect. Or you can see, well, you know, there really are some bottlenecks. And that can guide us in many ways. So what happens with people who are congenitally deaf?
将会很低。时间的某些方面将会很低。因此我们可以看到，哦，确实存在一个瓶颈。你所能看到的只是，哦，这是一个学习阅读有困难的孩子。你不知道他们身上发生了什么。如果你测量他们的声音处理，你可以看到，嗯，其实他们的声音处理没有任何问题。一切都很完美。或者你可以看到，嗯，你知道，确实存在一些瓶颈。这可以在很多方面指导我们。那么先天性失聪的人会发生什么？
Then how do they learn to read? Does their brain have to work in a different way? Yeah, it can work in a different way. And now many people who are congenitally death get cochlearly. implants, which enable them to actually bypass the ear and stimulate the hearing nerve, stimulate the brain directly, but they're still getting information from sound. So they're still making the same sound to meaning connections and would learn reading in much the same way.
那么他们是如何学习阅读的呢？他们的大脑必须以不同的方式工作吗？是的，它可以以不同的方式工作。现在许多先天性失聪的人都植入了人工耳蜗。植入物，使他们能够绕过耳朵并刺激听觉神经，直接刺激大脑，但他们仍然从声音中获取信息。所以他们仍在建立同样的声音到意义的连接，并且将以非常相似的方式学习阅读。
That said, if a person is not hearing at all, if they really are born congenitally deaf and they remain deaf, we know that the brain is remarkably. plastic and able to change based on what inputs it's getting so that if the sonic inputs are non-existent, then other parts of the brain will develop and will become stronger and learning to read and learning many other things can be done through these other channels. And then if you put electrodes on the head of somebody who's congenitally deaf and, you know, trying to understand what it is that they're processing. I mean, do you get some kind of reading?
话虽如此，如果一个人根本听不到声音，如果他们确实是先天性失聪并且保持失聪，我们知道大脑具有非凡的特性。具有可塑性，能够根据它所接受的输入发生变化，因此如果声音输入不存在，那么大脑的其他部分就会发育并变得更强大，并且可以通过这些其他渠道来学习阅读和学习许多其他事情。然后如果你把电极放在先天性失聪的人的头上，你知道，试图了解他们正在处理什么。我的意思是，你能得到某种读数吗？
Because I've seen the readings that you get from people who, two people hear the same thing. I think you've got the example of a Beatles song that's being played for two people. And then you can play back what it is that they've actually heard. And it's remarkable. I mean, it sounds just like the Beatles. But what do you get if you're dealing with somebody who really does not hear? Well, we haven't done that experiment, and it's probably one we should do. We have done actually quite a bit of work in people who are hearing impaired.
因为我见过从两个人听到同一事物的人那里得到的读数。我想你有一个正在为两个人播放的披头士乐队歌曲的例子。然后你可以回放他们实际听到的是什么。这太不可思议了。听起来就像披头士乐队一样。但是如果你面对的是一个真的听不到声音的人，你会得到什么呢？嗯，我们还没有做过那个实验，这可能是我们应该做的实验。事实上，我们在听力受损的人群中做了相当多的工作。
So we can see that the people who have a significant hearing loss, and especially one that they've acquired throughout their life, they have learned because the hearing brain is vast. And we can see people, I mean, just last week we had an 86-year-old musician with a very severe hearing loss in both of his ears. And his sound processing was remarkably excellent because, and here's the thing, the hearing brain is vast. So the hearing brain engages how we think, how we feel, what we know, what we remember, what we pay attention to, how we integrate our other senses. So this is the hearing brain. This is the brain that responds to vibrations. And, you know, and think of Beethoven.
所以我们可以看到，那些有严重听力损失的人，尤其是那些在他们一生中获得的听力损失，他们已经学会了，因为听觉大脑是广阔的。我们可以看到人们，就在上周，我们有一位86岁的音乐家，他的双耳都有非常严重的听力损失。他的声音处理非常出色，因为，这就是重点，听觉大脑是广阔的。因此，听觉大脑参与我们的思考、感受、已知、所记、注意力以及我们如何整合其他感官。这就是听觉大脑。这是对振动做出反应的大脑。而且，你知道，想想贝多芬。
Beethoven was deaf and composed some of the very best music that we have in our world because the hearing brain is vast. The hearing brain is vast. And this is, it's counter to the way many people think about the same. senses. They think about the senses as being these parallel things. They think about, you know, what we know, how we feel, even our psychological state. All of that is really part of how we sense the world and how the hearing brain in particular pulls together information from all of these sources in order to make sense of the world.
贝多芬失聪了，并创作了世界上最好的一些音乐，因为听觉大脑是广阔的。听觉大脑是广阔的。这与许多人对相同感官的看法背道而驰。他们认为感官是这些平行的东西。他们考虑我们所知道的、我们的感受，甚至我们的心理状态。所有这些实际上都是我们感知世界的方式的一部分，特别是听觉大脑如何将来自所有这些来源的信息汇集在一起，以便理解世界。
In the book, you talk about how several different types of expertise seem to give people a kind of auditory advantage. You've done research with musicians, athletes, and people who are bilingual. And what's really fascinating is that in all of these cases, these different skills seem to make people better at processing sound, but in different ways. Can you talk about that, how these different types of expertise in music, language, and athletics affect the hearing brain. So the punchline is we are what we do. And our lives and sound shape our brains. They shape who we are. So if I am a musician, I will have learned. And as we measure sound processing in the brain across musicians across the lifespan, what we see is that actually the processing of the harmonics
在书中，你谈到了几种不同类型的专业知识似乎如何赋予人们某种听觉优势。你对音乐家、运动员和双语者进行了研究。真正令人着迷的是，在所有这些情况下，这些不同的技能似乎使人们更好地处理声音，但方式不同。你能谈谈吗？这些在音乐、语言和田径方面的不同专业知识如何影响听力大脑？所以核心结论是我们就是我们所做的事情。我们的生活和声音塑造了我们的大脑。它们塑造了我们是谁。所以如果我是一个音乐家，我就会学会。当我们在整个生命周期中测量音乐家大脑中的声音处理时，我们看到的是，实际上对泛音的处理
and of timing are especially enhanced. They're especially strong. Remember, those are the ingredients of sound that we need for language. So by strengthening your music skills, you are strengthening your language skills. If you speak another language, what we see is that the strength of the the fundamental frequency, which is often associated with the pitch of a sound. So, for example, you know, there's a certain pitch associated with your voice, Kim, and with mine. And, you know, we think of auditory objects. You know, there is, you know, a fan whirring or any kind of sound that you can think of often has a pitch and it has a fundamental frequency.
时间也得到了特别的增强。它们特别强大。请记住，这些是我们语言所需的声音要素。因此，通过增强你的音乐技能，你正在增强你的语言技能。如果你说另一种语言，我们看到的是基频的强度，基频通常与声音的音调相关。例如，你知道，金，你的声音和我的声音都有一定的音调。并且，你知道，我们认为声音物体。你知道，有电风扇的呼呼声或你能想到的任何声音，通常都有音调并且它有基频。
And it turns out that if you speak another language, you're processing of that component of sound, that ingredient of sound, is really strong, which helps you distinguish one person speaking from another, for example. Because, you know, if you speak another language, you always have the languages you know, they're all in your head at the same time. But you get really good at distinguishing sound. based on the fundamental frequency. If you are an athlete,
事实证明，如果你会说另一种语言，你对声音的那个组成部分（声音的那个要素）的处理是非常强的，这有助于你区分一个人说话的声音和另一个人，例如。因为，你知道，如果你说另一种语言，你总是拥有你知道的语言，它们同时都在你的脑子里。但你真的很擅长辨别声音。基于基频。如果你是一名运动员，
you have an especially quiet brain. So, you know, all of us, I mean, our neurons right now are firing. The brain is always on. And there is static, electrical activity that happens constantly in the brain. But we have learned, and this is, you know, through work that we've done with Northwestern University's elite, Big 10 Division 1 athletes, we have a grant that the NIH is funding to study these athletes over five years.
你有一个特别安静的大脑。所以，你知道，我们所有人，我的意思是，我们现在的神经元正在放电。大脑一直在运转。大脑中不断产生静态电活动。但我们已经了解到，这是通过我们与西北大学精英十大联盟一级运动员合作完成的工作，我们获得了国立卫生研究院（NIH）的一笔资助，用于在五年内研究这些运动员。
And it's 500 of them, males, females across different sports. And what we find is that in healthy athletes, the noise, the background noise is suppressed. And so, you know, if you think of a signal being a sound that you want to hear and the noise being the impediment, they are able to engage with the world better because their senses, if you will, are heightened. I think you've also found that it doesn't really matter what sport that you're participating in. So while you could be a football player and there's a whole lot of noise happening on the field and you've got to be able to focus on, you know, what your colleagues are saying or what your coach is saying from the sidelines. but somebody who runs cross-country, which is a very solo kind of effort, that they still have the same kind of brain. That's fascinating how that has happened. Do you understand the ideology of that? Again, because sound and the hearing brain is so associated with movement and being very attuned to, you know, when you're running, you're hearing the sounds that your footfalls are making,
有500名男女运动员，来自不同的运动项目。我们发现，在健康的运动员中，噪音、背景噪音被抑制了。所以，如果你认为信号是你想听到的声音，噪音是障碍，他们能够更好地与世界互动，因为他们的感官，如果你愿意的话，更敏锐了。我想你也发现，你参加什么运动其实并不重要。因此，虽然你可能是一名橄榄球运动员，场上有大量的噪音，你必须能够专注于你的同事在说什么，或者你的教练在边线说什么。但跑越野赛的人，这是一种非常孤独的努力，他们仍然拥有相同的大脑。这是怎么发生的，真是太迷人了。你了解其中的意识形态吗？再次，因为声音和听觉大脑与运动密切相关，并且对以下方面非常敏感：当你跑步时，你会听到双脚落地的声音，
You know if you're running a certain way that feels good, that is efficient, you're getting sensory feedback all the time. You know, you're looking around you, you know, where are you placing your body? So I think any kind of deep athletic experience is going to require focused attention on the sensory environment. Let's talk about noise. You make the case in the book that exposure to unwanted noise harms not only people's ears but their brains. Why is that? What's happening to us when we're encountering noise? I think there is rising awareness that very loud sounds are bad for our ears and can damage our hearing as far as our ear is concerned.
你知道，如果你以某种感觉良好、高效的方式跑步，你就会一直获得感官反馈。你知道，你环顾四周，你知道，你把身体放在哪里？所以我认为任何深入的运动经验都需要对感官环境进行集中的关注。我们来谈谈噪音。你在书中提出，接触不想要的噪音不仅会损害人们的耳朵，还会损害他们的大脑。这是为什么呢？当我们遇到噪音时，我们身上发生了什么？我认为人们越来越认识到，非常大的声音对我们的耳朵不好，并且就我们的耳朵而言会损害我们的听力。
But there is very little awareness of the... really terrible impact that our noisy world can have on our brain. So I'm talking about sound that is moderate level intensity. You mentioned the truck at the beginning in your intro. If there is a truck idling outside, I will not pay attention to it. I'll just be talking to you. But when it turns off, when the guy cuts the ignition, I kind of go and the same is true.
但人们对……知之甚少。喧嚣的世界对我们的大脑造成的真正可怕的影响。所以我在谈论中等强度的声音。你在引言的开头提到了卡车。如果外面有一辆卡车在空转，我不会注意它。我只是在跟你说话。但当它熄火时，当那家伙切断点火装置时，我有点……同样的事情也是如此。
You're in your kitchen and the refrigerator cycles off. So we didn't even realize that we have been, you know, we're stressed. I do think that the extraneous noises that we have in our lives, many of which can be changed, can be eliminated, contribute to our feelings of stress because hearing, is our alarm sense. Again, from evolution, we know that hearing is what tells us if the sound I'm hearing, can I eat it, can I mate with it, do I need to run away?
你在厨房里，冰箱循环关闭。所以我们甚至没有意识到我们一直在，你知道，我们处于压力之中。我确实认为，我们生活中的无关噪音（其中许多是可以改变的、可以消除的）会导致我们的压力感，因为听觉是我们的警报感官。同样，从进化论中，我们知道听觉告诉我们我听到的声音是什么，我可以吃它吗，我可以和它交配吗，我需要逃跑吗？
This is very, very, very important information for survival. So we're all under this low level stress because of the sounds that we're hearing. Also, sounds distract us. So every time we get a notification of some kind, every time your neighbor is opening their car door, and you hear these constant sounds, they distract your focus. So we hear many people saying these days, I feel stressed and I can't seem to focus. And I think that a lot of good could come of honoring and being aware of how bad the effects of living in a noisy place and that noise in general has on the hearing brain and on our ability to make sense of the world around us. So how is this noise pollution affecting other animals? I mean, I think you've done some looking into what's happening to the other creatures around us who are maybe suffering from all the noise pollution that we're creating.
这对生存来说是非常非常重要的信息。因此，由于我们听到的声音，我们都承受着这种低水平的压力。此外，声音分散我们的注意力。所以每次我们收到某种通知，每次你的邻居打开车门，你听到这些持续的声音，它们都会分散你的注意力。因此，我们听到许多人最近说，我感到压力很大，而且似乎无法集中注意力。我认为，尊重并意识到生活在一个嘈杂的地方所产生的负面影响以及噪音对听觉大脑和我们理解周围世界的能力的总体影响，将会带来很多好处。那么这种噪音污染如何影响其他动物呢？我的意思是，我想你已经研究过我们周围的其他生物正在发生什么，它们可能正在遭受我们正在产生的所有噪音污染的痛苦。
So much. Underwater animals, whales, dolphins, they all communicate with sound, shipping, oil well digging. all of that really gets in the way of animal communication. And there were some wonderful experiments that were done during the first couple of days of the pandemic when, for example, shipping ceased. Also, people were noticing how you could hear the birds. And it wasn't because it was quieter. The birds were actually singing at a lower volume.
太多了。水下动物、鲸鱼、海豚，它们都通过声音交流，航运、油井挖掘。所有这些都真正阻碍了动物的交流。在大流行的头几天里，进行了一些精彩的实验，例如航运停止了。此外，人们注意到你是如何听到鸟叫声的。这并不是因为更安静。鸟类实际上以较低的音量唱歌。
but they were singing at a lower volume because they no longer had to compete with the racket that we humans are making. And so they were producing quieter songs, but songs that were richer in texture. And, you know, the success of a species depends on, well, in birds, the male bird sings and the female bird chooses. So if the male is able to sing a fancier song, he's going to likely get more female companions. But this is so important. It's important for plants.
但它们以较低的音量唱歌，因为它们不再需要与我们人类制造的喧嚣竞争。因此，它们产生的歌曲更安静，但质感更丰富。而且，一个物种的成功取决于，在鸟类中，雄鸟唱歌，雌鸟选择。因此，如果雄鸟能够唱出更优美的歌曲，他很可能会获得更多的雌性伴侣。但这非常重要。这对植物很重要。
It's important for the life in the soil. The sounds that we make affect most living things. So we are harming ourselves, and we are certainly harming other. living creatures and their ability to know where they are to, you know, go about their business of thriving. In your book, you also talk about the connection between sound and rhythm and how important that is, and certainly it makes a big difference in how humans communicate, but I thought it was really interesting how animals use rhythm as well. But not very many animals have rhythm. Why is that?
这对土壤中的生命很重要。我们发出的声音影响着大多数生物。所以我们正在伤害自己，我们肯定也在伤害其他生物。活着的生物以及它们知道自己在哪里、继续繁荣发展日常事务的能力。在你的书中，你还讨论了声音和节奏之间的联系以及这是多么重要，当然这极大地改变了人类交流的方式，但我认为动物也使用节奏非常有趣。但没有多少动物有节奏。为什么会这样？
And the animals that have rhythm, where do they get it from? Where do we get it from? And the fact that you can't make a chimpanzee dance, but a cockatoo may dance to music. Why? So everyone knows that there is rhythm in music. And there's so much rhythm in language. Rhythm tells us when things stop and start. And every Martin Luther King day.
有节奏的动物，它们是从哪里得到节奏的？我们是从哪里得到它的？事实上，你不能让黑猩猩跳舞，但凤头鹦鹉可能会伴着音乐跳舞。为什么？每个人都知道音乐中有节奏。语言中也有很多节奏。节奏告诉我们事情何时停止和开始。在每一个马丁·路德·金纪念日。
my husband and I listen to his, I have dream speech. And, you know, the rhythm, it's a song in his voice is really what carries you, it integrates the experience tremendously because there are also rhythms, the rhythms outside the head, their rhythms, brain rhythms inside the head. If I were reading you his speech just in the way I normally would be reading a recipe, you'd be looking at your watch, you'd be, you know, you wouldn't want to be listening to that. So it turns out that kids who have difficulty moving and tapping to a beat can have some language problems. You asked about other animals.
我和我丈夫听他的“我有一个梦想”演讲。你知道，节奏，他声音中的歌声确实是带你前进的东西，它极大地整合了体验，因为还有节奏，头脑外部的节奏，有节奏，头脑内部的大脑节奏。如果我只是像平常读食谱那样读他的演讲，你会看你的表，你会，你知道，你不会想听那个的。事实证明，难以随着节拍移动和拍打的孩子可能会有一些语言问题。你问过其他动物。
It seems that rhythm is especially important in animals that do vocal learning. So, you know, some birds and bats and many sea creatures, whales, you know, these are animals that can move rhythmically, and they also learn by imitation. They learn by imitation. And so that seems to be, the rhythm seems to be an important part of this. and something that we have been very interested in, you know, in that we find that if a child has a music education and makes music, their rhythm skills are enhanced,
似乎节奏对于进行声音学习的动物尤其重要。所以，你知道，一些鸟类、蝙蝠和许多海洋生物、鲸鱼，你知道，这些是能够有节奏地运动的动物，它们也通过模仿学习。它们通过模仿来学习。所以这似乎是，节奏似乎是其中的重要部分。我们非常感兴趣的事情，你知道，我们发现如果一个孩子接受音乐教育并制作音乐，他们的节奏技能就会得到增强，
as are their brain rhythm skills are enhanced, and some of the language benefits that we see with music are coming from rhythm. But rhythm has a wonderful synchronizing, part of it, I mean, just inherently, we synchronize. And neurons inherently, when they are firing together, they synchronize. You have the synchrony of neural activity. One of the things that I hadn't mentioned is that making sense of sound is one of the hardest jobs that we ask our brain to do. So it requires this microsecond timing precision. So if you get hit in the head,
随着他们的大脑节奏技能的增强，我们从音乐中看到的一些语言益处也来自节奏。但节奏有一个极好的同步部分，我的意思是，本质上，我们是同步的。神经元在本质上一起放电时会同步。你拥有神经活动的同步性。我没有提到的一件事是，理解声音是我们要求大脑做的最困难的工作之一。因此它需要微秒级的时间精度。如果你头部受到撞击，
so for example, if you have a concussion, you're going to to disrupt this sound processing. And some of the work that we have been doing is showing how it is that if you have sustained a concussion, sound processing is disrupted. We can measure this automatically. It can give us a lot of information about the status of an athlete's injury, can help us inform return to play decisions, can help us monitor treatment, all kinds of. of things. But, you know, why am I saying this? Because it relates to rhythm. We have some
例如，如果你有脑震荡，你就会破坏这种声音处理。我们一直在做的一些工作表明，如果你遭受了脑震荡，声音处理是如何被破坏的。我们可以自动测量这个。它可以为我们提供大量关于运动员受伤状况的信息，可以帮助我们为重返赛场的决定提供信息，可以帮助我们监测治疗，各种各样的。的事情。但是，我为什么要这么说呢？因为它与节奏有关。我们有一些
early findings showing that rhythm skills are disrupted after you've had a concussion. And so rhythm training is something that is a way in which we can use our hearing brain to improve brain health. This has certainly been shown in many neurological disorders. So rhythm, rhythm is fundamental for health and for communication. And related to that, you know, when we were talking a few moments ago about the types of expertise that seem to give people an auditory advantage, and one of those is studying music. Does listening to music have the same effect on people's brains? It doesn't have the same effect. Surely it has some effect, but the ones that we have studied are, you know, who have you become based on your life in sound?
早期研究结果表明，脑震荡后节奏技能会受到损害。因此，节奏训练是我们利用听觉大脑改善大脑健康的一种方式。这在许多神经系统疾病中肯定已经得到了证实。所以节奏，节奏是健康和交流的基础。与此相关的是，你知道，当我们前不久谈到似乎赋予人们听觉优势的专业知识类型时，其中之一就是学习音乐。听音乐对人们的大脑有同样的效果吗？它没有相同的效果。当然它有一些效果，但我们研究过的是，你知道，你根据你的声音生活变成了谁？
So the things that you do a lot of, the languages that you speak, the music that you make, when you actively learn a musical instrument, it doesn't matter if you're good or not, but if you really, if you spend some time making music, you are making the music. you are making these deep sound to meaning connections. You are engaging your vast hearing brain, which engages our cognitive sensory motor and reward systems. So, you know, we are able then to strengthen our ability to process sound even when we are asleep. You know, for example, you know, you pay attention to the sounds that are important to you. If you're asleep and I put scalp electrodes on your brain, you know, we will measure a response when we say Kim because, you know, you have learned that that is a sound that is worth paying
所以你经常做的事情，你说的语言，你制作的音乐，当你积极学习一件乐器时，你是否擅长并不重要，但如果你真的，如果你花一些时间制作音乐，你就是在制作音乐。你正在建立这些深厚的声音到意义的连接。你正在吸引你广阔的听觉大脑，它吸引了我们的认知感觉运动和奖励系统。所以，你知道，即使在我们睡着的时候，我们也能够增强我们处理声音的能力。你知道，例如，你知道，你会注意对你重要的声音。如果你睡着了，我把头皮电极放在你的大脑上，你知道，当我们说“金”时，我们会测量到一个反应，因为，你知道，你已经了解到这是一个值得注意的声音
attention to. So you automatically, we learn based on what we do, we automatically learn to process sound differently. And this is what we have learned with playing either a musical instrument, singing, of course, counts. But as far as listening, just listening, you know, I like to say that you're not going to get muscles. You're not going to become physically fit watching sports. So, you know, actually, you know, partaking in the sports will fundamentally change you. And I believe, at least this is what we have seen, that making music will fundamentally change how your brain automatically
注意力。所以你自动地，我们根据我们所做的事情进行学习，我们自动学会以不同的方式处理声音。这就是我们通过弹奏乐器、唱歌（当然算数）学到的东西。但就听力而言，仅仅听，你知道，我喜欢说你不会长肌肉。看体育比赛你是不会变得身体健康的。所以，你知道，实际上，参与体育运动会从根本上改变你。我相信，至少这是我们所看到的，制作音乐会从根本上改变你的大脑自动的方式
processes sound. Well, last question. I know we could go on and on, but I know we do have to wrap this up. So I'm going to ask you what recommendations you would give to our listeners who want to think more carefully about how they arrange their sonic world and maybe make some improvements to it overall. My recommendations, you know, based on, I'm a biologist, based on the biology that I live and breathe every day, is strengthen the sound mind. Strengthen the sound mind. Strengthen the sound mind. by making music, by learning languages, by being a bird watcher, which is, of course, you're listening. And, you know, read to your kids. I so often see, you know, parents on their phone and they're, you know, walking with their kid.
处理声音。好吧，最后一个问题。我知道我们可以没完没了地讲下去，但我知道我们必须结束这一切。所以我要问你，对于那些想要更仔细地思考如何安排他们的声音世界并可能对它进行整体改进的听众，你有什么建议？我的建议，你知道，基于，我是一名生物学家，基于我每天生活和呼吸的生物学，是加强声音思维。加强声音思维。加强声音思维。通过制作音乐、学习语言、成为一名观鸟者（当然也就是聆听）来做到这一点。并且，你知道，给你的孩子读书。我经常看到，你知道，父母在他们的手机上，他们，你知道，和他们的孩子一起走路。
And I'm thinking, you know, talk to your kid. Don't talk to your phone. What is so important about sound is that sound connects us. Sound connects us. So use this ability to connect with your loved ones, teach them how important that kind of connection through sound is. And with respect to noise, ask yourself, is this noise necessary?
我在想，你知道，跟你的孩子说话。不要跟你的手机说话。声音如此重要的一点是，声音将我们联系在一起。声音将我们联系在一起。所以利用这种能力与你所爱的人联系，教导他们这种通过声音进行的联系是多么重要。关于噪音，问问自己，这种噪音是必要的吗？
You know, I can turn the thing off on my, car door so that it won't beep every time I open and close a door. You know, there are things that our society really should be paying attention to, you know, for example, you know, if you think of an airport that's a noisy place or even a grocery store. So there inherently, there's going to be sounds, which are perfectly necessary sounds. But you know, do we need every time you scan a barcode, do you need to hear, be, be, be, and think about the poor person who is on the other side of that all day long. I mean, you're just enduring it for a little while. Similarly, one of the things is, it's fall now, and the days have been so wonderful, and the
你知道，我可以关掉车门上的那个东西，这样每次我打开和关上车门时它就不会哔哔叫了。你知道，有些事情我们的社会确实应该予以关注，例如，你知道，如果你认为机场是一个嘈杂的地方甚至是杂货店。因此，本质上会有声音，这是完全必要的声音。但你知道，每次你扫描条形码时，你都需要听到“哔、哔、哔”，并想想整天在另一端的可怜人吗。我的意思是，你只是忍受了一会儿。同样，其中一件事是，现在是秋天，日子一直很好，
leaf blowers are ridiculous in terms of the amount of, and how anyone in our community can, on the one side of their mouth say that they are concerned about global warming. And on the other hand, you know, condone using these leaf blowers, I don't understand. But the fact is that even if they are a block away, I don't even see them, you have this droning that is going on like the truck that is impeding our ability to focus and think. And so to the extent that we can take a stand in our personal lives, in our educational lives, in our lives with medicine, and really think about the importance of sound, how important it is for our health in so many ways. There really are ways that we can strengthen our sound mind and that we can think of ways to
吹叶机在数量上是荒谬的，我们社区里的任何人怎么能一面说他们关心全球变暖。另一方面，你知道，纵容使用这些吹叶机，我不明白。但事实是，即使它们在一个街区之外，我甚至看不到它们，你也会听到像卡车那样扰乱我们注意力和思考能力的轰鸣声。因此，在我们在个人生活、教育生活、医疗生活中表明立场，真正思考声音的重要性，它在很多方面对我们的健康有多么重要。确实有方法可以让我们加强有声思维，并且我们可以想出方法来
keep it as healthy as possible. Well, thank you. I appreciate very much. You're taking the time to talk to me today. I want to assure you that I have a rake, and that's what I've been using on my leaves and we'll continue to do so. But thank you, Dr. Krause. It's been really interesting. And that's a nice sound. It is. It is.
尽可能保持健康。好的，谢谢。非常感谢。你今天抽出时间跟我谈话。我想向你保证我有一把耙子，这就是我一直在叶子上使用的东西，并且将继续这样做。但谢谢你，克雷文博士。这真的很有趣。这是一个好声音。它是。它是。
Thanks, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening.
谢谢，金。您可以在我们的网站 www. www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的剧集。如果您喜欢您听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以给我们发电子邮件 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Kondayan）。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美国心理学协会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击抄本中的任意句子发表评论。